well i hope you're ready for this one
we're in for a wild ride
nbc news says mandating vaccines amid a
worker shortage could spell trouble for
corporate america it's so hard to find
workers now that if you know a certain
percentage of your workers are going to
quit due to a vaccine mandate you're not
going to disrupt that said one hr expert
so we're in a labor shortage we've got
10.1 million job openings
and
we don't even have that many people
available for for work they've said now
the ratio of jobs to people is 0.9 down
from one it used to be like for every
one job we had people who weren't
looking for work
now we have more jobs i guess you could
say it's a good thing it means like
people are like hey we're open for
business we need employees but
it's actually a really bad thing yeah it
means
the economy won't be able to recover we
don't have the people nobody will work
and now that they're doing mass mandates
and vaccine mandates and a lot of these
businesses people are going to quit it's
going to get worse
and also yeah i mean
i wouldn't want to go to work and
dehumanize be dehumanized and to
humanize the people around me i wouldn't
want to do that either especially you
know when i could buy a 300 cheeseburger
that's right if uh if inflation gets to
those levels then you can have your 300
cheeseburger yeah you know what i really
love i made a point where i said when we
had john schneider on the show papa john
he mentioned in the members segment that
he knows a pizzeria where they're paying
35 bucks an hour to people for people to
make pizzas which is that's unheard of
yeah and then i was like okay so enjoy
your 50 pizza and then i get all these
people being like
tim in sweden cheeseburgers are still
only five dollars and they have
sweden is like one of the largest
weapons exporters per capita don't come
to me and talk to me about what's
sustaining their economy okay i'm not
saying that quite literally overnight
your pizza's gonna cost 50 because
they're paying 35 bucks an hour right
now
what i'm saying is
sure at a store with massive volume
where they're doing hundreds of
cheeseburgers per hour they can
accommodate higher salaries and wages
and they should absolutely sure
mcdonald's and burning all these places
they should pay more they have massive
profits same is true for walmart but
when it comes to a small mom-and-pop
pizzeria if you've got to pay someone 35
bucks an hour how many pizzas are you
making per hour it's going that's that's
a 50 increase in labor costs yes your
pizza is going to go from 12 to 14
and then people are like ah it's only
two bucks who cares i'm willing to pay
that if it means that people are going
to have better salaries right and better
wages health insurance and health
insurance people deserve health
insurance
i think the bigger problem is that
health insurance shouldn't come from
employers right we need to find a
solution that makes no sense but the the
issue ultimately is that it ripples
throughout the entire economy it's not
about the one pizza costing 14 bucks for
you right now it's that the guy who
can't feed his family because it's too
expensive now asks his boss for a raise
and it goes up across the board
yeah it does yeah though that's
inflation that's the problem with it
yeah well so this is the these mandates
what people don't realize is that people
are going to leave cities they're going
to quit their jobs it's going to make
the economies worse in all of our big
cities
maybe yeah no it is going to make i mean
i'm not going to go anywhere that
requires me to show paperwork in order
to enter i specifically absolutely will
not i'm going to make it impossible for
me to do that i'm going to like destroy
my vaccine card so that i can't
you know i can't people have already
lost them
they ought to like let's all lose them
there was a video in italy they're
burning their their passes
well they should var this on the show
and i thought it was a really good point
because i hadn't considered it he said
the problem with vaccine mandates for
like new york for instance that a lot of
people already lost to their cards yeah
it was too big it didn't fit in your
wallet they know what to do with it
nobody cares like i got vaccinated and
that's done now
the other thing too is they kept saying
they weren't gonna do it so people are
like oh okay i guess i don't need this
well the federal government promised
they said it over and over again i mean
you had jen saki in the briefing room
being asked this question over and over
are there going to be federal vaccine
passports and no we're not going to have
a vaccine credential that we're not
going to do that absolutely will not we
will work with businesses who intend to
do that and make sure that they do that
and in the appropriate way there will
not be a federal credential
even if there's not a federal credential
there should be
a disallowance of any sort of credential
that mandates that that should just not
even be allowed what was that mean um i
think who mentioned it it was like a
whole lot of people who uh
what was it
oh man i'm forgetting it because i just
forgot it was on top of my tongue okay
it was like a whole bunch of people who
were like anti-fascists are now show me
your papers yeah oh yeah something like
that like switch from yeah yeah last
year yeah it was like opposed the
dictator now it's show me your papers
not funny how that works the interesting
thing too with trump is when you ask
people what were some of his
authoritarian fascist policies they
can't actually name any it was just
resist the individual that you really
really think is over the top and
obnoxious did you see ben shapiro on
bill maher
yeah so one of the things that bill
maher said when he mentions benchmarks
and i talked to him last week i did an
interview with benjamin that was
interesting yeah he has the the
authoritarian moment his new book and
bill maher was like i thought you were
going to talk about trump and i'm like
please tell me trump what i can we can
talk about war and foreign policy
because that's what every president's
been doing and i'll agree with you there
for sure but trump did a whole lot of
nothing in a lot of ways yes that's
great he didn't shut down the riots he
wagged his finger and said oh the
radical left and then didn't do anything
that's a really good impression
so they call him an authoritarian and
i'm like for what why yeah there's no
there's nothing to back it up it's just
a word that this is used for someone you
don't like it's the other it's that
other thing i guess the idea the one
thing i could say is the
people who are willing to belie like
just follow trump no matter what trump
said
but that wasn't the majority of
conservatives conservatives like the
republicans the people voted for trump
were more than willing to criticize him
as evidenced by the fact that you
actually have this weird agree like
independent voters and republicans are
leaning in the same direction right now
clearly independents people who probably
vote libertarian and third party
aren't republicans
but they all recognize the economy is
not good but for some reason the
democrats you want to know what
authoritarian is authoritarian is when
the economy is in flames
nobody's working massive job openings
we've got uh
warnings from our mainstream media
saying this is going to get worse
because the mandates and the democrats
being like i think the economy is going
great
you know fairly good i get confused when
you say the democrats are you do you
mean the the politicians or the people
that are registered
i'm referring to uh poll which says
democratic voters believe in the economy
so they're not democrats like they are
only the people the only the politicians
are considered democrats the voters are
just people they're not democrats or
republicans so the way the polling works
it asks you which party you're
affiliated with
because when you say the democratic
party's full of idiots i think of
congress and that in a lot of ways i
agree with you but the people that
register as democrats i don't want to
put them in that in that ballpark that's
that's but they are they're the ones who
are doing this voting i've registered a
democrat for like two
is the economy doing good no it's
terrible why is it then that independent
voters and republicans recognize that
but democratic voters think the economy
is doing good because they watch msnbc
and i think libby that's what it means
when they say rachel maddow they
identify as democrats they all believe
the same thing whatever the authority
tells them they follow that's
authoritarianism mindset that's
authoritarianism strict adherence to
what the authority tells you it's like
michael brzezinski said it's her job to
tell you what to think remember
it's the narrative i mean it's it's
that's what everybody is fighting over
and media too that's what everyone is
fighting over it's like uh
every you know there's like two stories
that are being told and the media is
arguing over which story is the accurate
story and people aren't wanting to just
put out facts and say this is the thing
that happened this is the thing that
this person said i don't think the media
is doing that i think you don't think so
you don't think that the media is like
intentionally skewing towards a specific
narrative they are but you but uh what
you said was something more specific
what i'm saying is
they're not trying
what the media is doing is they're
saying whatever at the time will benefit
them politically that's all they're
doing they're opportunistic they're not
talking about making anyone here to
yes
and the problem the authoritarian
authoritarianism comes from the people
who are like
oh rachel maddow said the other day that
she doesn't trust vaccines but today she
says she does so i guess i will too
that's authoritarianism rachel maddow
said so don lemon said so let's just do
whatever they say
meanwhile you have regular people who
are like dude like i i i vote republican
for the first time you know uh donald
trump and i never i voted for obama
before him in 2020 yeah
the uh i don't want to vote for i
wouldn't vote for trump again probably
you would not vote for no i think
desantis is the right is the better
choice but to be completely honest i'd
rather have a dave smith
although i recognize the libertarian
party's
weakness in terms of the two-party
system of this country we'll see how
things play out i really really despise
the idea of voting against the democrats
or voting against the republicans yeah
but i think desantis has done fairly
well i think he's a pretty interesting
guy yeah so we'll see he has actual
ideas
if trump comes on here and talks about
fusion then i will fully support him but
really yeah if he keeps
doing 20th century technology he's got
nothing i got nothing i think trump has
shown us that
look he may have been the molotov
cocktail in the machine he may have been
the ball in the china shop we got to oil
that man yeah you like that ring in that
ring
but he made so many mistakes yeah he
should have fired a ton more people but
i think a lot of people saw trump as an
opportunity for something outside the
establishment that's disturbing because
that leads to authoritarianism because
there's no it doesn't yeah the
authoritarian is crackback is is against
that authoritarian mindset of like i
love this guy he's going to just break
it
i don't know about that i mean because
they're just blindly following him and
so now we're getting
a revolt again i don't think it was
blind following of trump right and i was
opposed to trump in 2016. um i
definitely was not in favor you know i
went to the women's march whatever
stupid but
but i think that what you had at the
time when trump was elected were
you know half of the population did not
see their views or their values
reflected
in any aspect of american culture or
political life
not in arts academia entertainment
anywhere not in media so when trump came
along and was like hey 75 million people
who
don't see your values or views reflected
anywhere in the country in
literally anything you're capable of
subscribing to i'm over here i can
listen to you
i can give voice to you right like
that's sort of what he was about he was
like a figure that was able to do that
so when he was taken away right those
people are back to having absolutely no
voice only now they're thoroughly
publicly vilified as opposed to just
being vilified which they were
previously and ian you were describing
more so anarchy than authoritarianism if
someone says i will not adhere to the
authority structure and i will put in
place someone who is chaotic and
destructive to that system that is
anti-authoritarian
a lot of people as michael moore
explained were looking at the human
molotov cocktail the biggest fu to the
machine they hated the authority they
hate the establishment so they didn't
support trump some people were were
zealots for trump no joke that whatever
trump said would say they'd be like yes
and they believe crazy things but that's
a small a smaller element most people
were just like we need something
as a wedge in the door
something that's going to get us off
this broken path
now for me i didn't vote for trump in
2016. i was like i don't care about
either these people and then in 2020
trump put out his agenda with like
school choice on it the opposition to
critical race applied principles things
like that he said we're going to pull he
was actively working to get our troops
out of it out of afghanistan and i was
like that right there right get the
troops home end this stuff okay i'll
vote for that plus joe biden's insane
right that's a terrible idea thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show come back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time